I'm struggling to figure out given that
and also being an
entrepreneur like should I I feel like I
should have more than six months
emergency fund save so I'm trying to
figure out what's the right number there
and I'm kind of feeling like no matter
where I get it to I feel like it's not
enough so I'm
curious what event in your mind could
occur or would occur that would require
more than six months of your expenses to
be
covered you know as an entrepreneur I
feel like I'm always thinking worst case
scenarios I'm like if there's a big
recession or who knows if all of our
business goes what is the likelihood
you're going to go six months with zero
income probably pretty unlikely yeah
like because as an entrepreneur you
would like get a
job true before that happened right yes
sir